I'm here with my culinary partner in crime,
chef Pilar Valdes.
(audience applauding)
Now, Pilar and I had a very special Thanksgiving together
that is actually a huge center piece
of our new cookbook, called "Rebel Homemaker"
(audience applauding)
and here it is,
it is the Thanksgiving
Roulade!
(audience applauding)
And now we have
our own magazine.
That's right, we do,
and, actually, the centerpiece of it
is this dish, because, let's face it,
all magazines around this time of year
are trying to show us inventive ways
to approach a Thanksgiving meal.
So, this one has my heart.
I'm so excited to share it with you.
Also joining us is a newly engaged couple,
your first Thanksgiving as an engaged couple.
Congratulations.
Thank you, Drew.
You've been together for two and a half years?
Yes.
That's right.
All right, this was Maria Colona and Alex Miranda
and I wanna welcome you to our Thanksgiving
roulade.
Roulade.
Ooh, thank you.
I'm excited. (laughs)
Have you guys ever made Thanksgiving dinner together?
We have not, he has helped my family cook,
he's an amazing cook, but we're excited for this year
to be engaged and yeah.
Yeah.
Are you guys gonna
spend it with family?
Yes.
Okay, let's show everybody this beautiful take
on the classic flavors of Thanksgiving,
done in this gorgeous gourmet, beautiful way.
You guys ready?
All right, so basically what Drew was saying,
we took all those flavors
and we stuff it in a rolled turkey breast.
So, why don't we start there
with the pounding out of the Turkey?
(audience laughing)
Okay, so, I'm very nervous.
So, the turkey breast actually comes kind of,
if you imagine it without the saran wrap, this way,
and you're gonna slice
and then cut through, not all the way,
and you just kind of open it up, like a book,
sandwich it in between two pieces of plastic wrap.
How hard do I pound it?
Not super hard.
'Cause you know I wanna
pound it really hard.
Ever so slightly, gently.
Yeah, you're doing it,
and you wanna do outward motions, basically.
There you go, an even thickness.
You're doing great, Drew, I like this dance move.
Is this gonna be your Thanksgiving dance move?
Okay, I think that's great.
I am a rebel homemaker, so one last hit.
So let's get to the stuffing.
So what we did for the stuffing is, again,
those classic Thanksgiving flavors.
We sauteed shallots and celery and garlic and onions,
and then mushrooms, and as soon as the mushrooms
start to caramelize, that's what you have in here, Drew,
we basically de-glazed it with a little bit of white wine
and you're scraping those beautiful bits up, basically.
Okay, now I'm gonna add in some chopped parsley,
chopped walnuts and dried cranberries or cherries
and give it a good stir.
And you're actually gonna lay the stuffing
in an even layer across of your turkey breast
that we've pounded out,
and you're gonna spread it
all the way to the sides, completely flat.
And then what you're gonna do, here comes the roulade part,
you ready to roll?
Do it.
All right, so I like to use
a little bit of plastic wrap underneath
that keeps things a little neat,
little cleaner.
And also grippable.
Exactly.
As well as hygienic.
And you can see, like I'm just pulling it in
and rolling, so you're getting this perfect roulade.
So you have your roulade here
and you're gonna tie it,
and all that does
is basically keep the roulade very compact.
All right, and we're gonna actually, so Drew,
I actually have a fully tied one
and I'm gonna start searing it off.
So we have a hot pan over here,
and I'm just gonna sear.
(oil sizzling)
And all you're gonna do is basically sear this
roughly two minutes on each side.
So two minutes, four sides all around
and you're just looking to get...
(audience laughing)
(knife buzzing)
Well, this is not how chefs do it, but it works.
And then you sear it basically to a golden brown,
you're gonna put the glaze on,
and the glaze is just little bit of tamari,
a little balsamic, a little orange juice for the sweetness,
and when that puppy is all glazed up,
we're just gonna add the leftover stuffing on the side,
and then you pop the whole thing in 325 degrees
and it's gonna roast for about 40 to 50 minutes
until it's done, so until the internal temperature
reaches, thank you.
(audience applauding)
150, you wanna pick it up?
You take it out.
All right.
Perfect, thank you.
There we go.
(audience clapping)
I'm gonna bring it back here to slice.
So how do you think Thanksgiving's gonna go this year
as a newly engaged couple?
Do you go to one house for a little bit
and then the other house?
How do you guys roll?
Yeah, so I usually stop by my family's house first
and then go for dinner to Maria's house. (laughs)
And we spend the
evening together.
Yeah, we have a big blowout
at my house, my mom and my aunt do all kinds of cooking.
Really?
Yeah.
My family doesn't cook so much (laughs) so.
But you do a lot of cooking.
I do the cooking, yeah.
He does.
My aunt's happy for the help.
Ah, there you go.
Yes. (laughs)
Okay.
(knife buzzing)
This is my favorite part.
Woo.
That looks so fun.
(Alex laughing)
(knife buzzing)
Today you want a nice cut, that is pretty--
Beautiful.
That's right.
(audience clapping)
(Maria and Alex laughing)
(knife buzzing)
Nailed it.
Brava.
I mean, look at how
absolutely beautiful this is.
Nicely done.
Yes, ooh.
Gorgeous.
And that is, at the end of the day,
what it should look like.
Beautiful.
(audience applauding)
And then you can plate it really beautifully.
Shall we taste it, because--
Yes.
Mmm, that's so good.
A little garnish for ya.
You can dress it up,
make it look nice.
That's right.
It's so juicy.
This is so good.
Well done, Drew.
(audience clapping)
So if you go in the cookbook or the magazine,
you will find Pilar's beautiful Turkey roulade
that I am so proud to be a part of,
and thank you for reinventing Thanksgiving for me, Pilar.
I really, really, really, really, really love this dish
that you made.
Maria and Alex are gonna stay with us.
I've got a quick and delicious recipe
that makes a fantastic side.
It is low-fi,
and I guarantee you
everyone's gonna fight over it.
And we're making Thanksgiving dinner together.
As demonstrated, Pilar displayed
her gorgeous gourmet turkey roulade,
because she is an extraordinary chef,
and I am a home cook,
so I wanna show you a dish
that basically anybody could make.
I love a traditional boxed, yummy
low-fi corn casserole, okay,
and this is the dish
that everybody's gonna be scratching each other over.
So melted margarine, two kinds of corn,
canned, creamed corn,
and as I like to say, nibblets.
(audience laughing)
All right, here you have your corn
right out of the box, right there.
You're also gonna incorporate two eggs and sour cream.
I'm just gonna follow the instructions.
It can't be easier, it's one bowl,
it's old-school, it's super classic.
I think I'm gonna get the whisk out
'cause that'll actually blend it better,
and you just cannot fail with this dish.
And the way I grew up is, you know,
we ate canned and boxed corn pudding,
and I loved it.
And just--
(indistinct) Where
does he go?
(audience clapping)
375 for 30 minutes, please and thank you.
See, you whip out a gourmet roulade,
I whip out some boxed and canned cream pudding,
corn pudding.
That's okay with us.
And they go together beautifully.
They really do.
Check that out.
Also, if you're gonna make a giant Thanksgiving dinner,
you are going to need some sides to be a little bit simpler.
I'm going right in.
And I think you guys have
as well.
And you guys have some.
All right, one here.
Woo hoo.
This is my square.
I'm gonna go
straight from here.
Thank you, exactly.
Don't worry about us.
It's so moist.
So good.
So good, it's good.
That corn.
It's good.
It's delicious.
Do you like it?
Yes.
It wasn't hard to make, as you could see.
It was not, but it's so good.
It's very moist, so,
thank you, Maria.
And Alex.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much, everybody,
for choosing to spend your time with us,
we make this show for you, so take it with you.